so can you unpack that for us what do  you what do you mean by past present  future lives in a stripper gesture so  the the short answer is in 3d linear  regular everyday time-space reality time  kind of goes like this past is over here  futures over here and we're right here  in the now but if you think about  reality as a whole a lot of the  spiritual teachers and leaders a lot of  the great ones say there is only now and  time isn't like this which is a  horizontal time is like this which is  vertical so it really depends on the  orientation that you want to have if you  think oh you have a past life that was a  genius scientist or a rock guide or a  fashionista or a really fit or really  inspiring or a great romantic and you  want to tap into that past life or tap  into it for some other reason maybe to  heal the wound affect your personality  in a certain way  then it's much easier to think of life's  and lifetimes not just you know oh maybe